hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter three
of his work the manalo Jim and stone is
going to make yet another argument about
the existence of a Supreme Being now in
Chapter one and two it was framed in
terms of a supreme good that is a good
above all of the goods through which
everything is good and supreme greatness
in this case he's actually going to talk
about it being as a chapter title says
there is a certain nature through him
through whom all existing things exist
or have there being and who exists
through himself in a supreme among all
other existing things so what we're
talking about here is you might say
Supreme Being car excellent supreme
being as being supreme being has
existence from which all other existing
things exist now he's been I think an
argument that I've laid out here on the
board then in chapter 4 he's going to
follow this up with a few other
reflections that we'll mention at the
end of this where is he trying to go
with all of this well the conclusion is
going to be that there is some one thing
that's going to be in this case the
Supreme Being that alone exists most
greatly and supremely of all things and
that
you know the best and greatest and
supreme among all existing things
how does he agree to get to that well
he's got a line of argument that works
by saying it could be this way or this
way but it can't be this way so it has
to be this way so let's go through all
these alternatives that he lays out he
begins by saying whatever exists and you
know we're thinking about existence as
we know it we don't really exist we know
all sorts of things exist ranging from
pieces of chalk to truck boards to video
cameras to bookstore whatever you want
whatever exists exists through something
not from or through nothing this is an
idea that in some is going to work out
it and you might say greater depth and
detail and later chapters so that's
enough to be able to say about that at
this point we don't need to worry over
much about you know precisely what
existing through something means at this
point what I want to get across is that
he's beginning by saying how do things
end up existing it can't be a just from
nothing there has to be something that
makes them exist something that provides
them existence ya know he says either
there is some one thing through which
all existing things exist now you know
through which their their existence
comes to be possessed through which they
come into being however you want to
parse this up but there's one thing or
there are multiple things and notice
that he's not saying that that
everything in the universe is going to
be self causing or you know bringing
itself into existence he's going to be
considering the possibility that there's
one ultimate source for existence or
that there could be several and he says
if we get the one if we start with that
then we've already gotten to our
conclusion
that's what I was trying to prove in the
first place so let's assume that this
isn't the case then we have several
things and then we have a few different
options now the first of the ones that
he talks about is there is one thing
through which they exist I put that at
the bottom because that's where we're
actually going the other two options are
each of those several things that is
providing the existence to other
existing things so that's something that
is a a quad something that is a ground
and metaphysical foundation for other
things each of those could exist through
itself so that each one is you might say
independent of the other ones we're
looking at the relation between them
right or they exist through one another
in some sort of reciprocal quantization
one of them brings the other into
existence and yet at the same time that
other one is bringing the first one into
existence and then they bring everything
else into existence or there is one
thing through which they exist in which
case we're actually back here to there
is one thing through which all the
existing things exist we just had a
middleman or a set of extra steps along
the way so if we wind up with this
option right here we're really going
back than to this position right here
which is the conclusion that Anton is
attempting to prove so what we want to
do that is look very carefully at these
two options
Ansem says if each of them exists
through itself then there's surely
someone power or nature of self existing
a characteristic capacity whatever we
want to call it each of them he has to
have this power or nature of self
existing in order to exist through
themselves but in that case
what is actually causing them to exist
their own capacity for self existence in
which case there is one thing through
which all of those other things exist
and so this really takes us back down to
here so if we if we accept this option
we end up here and we end up here it and
we're out the conclusion so he says all
things that exist more truly through
that one thing than through the several
things that cannot exist without that
one thing we're tracing things back to a
primal unity of causality what about
this this other option they exist
through one another there's a kind of
reciprocity between them he says no
reasoning allows for several things to
exist through each other
why so this you know this is something
that we can imagine but not something or
something that we can say we can
formulate but it's not something that if
we think through and some says that we
can we can really cognize in a way that
makes sense so he says this it's
irrational to think that something
exists through which through that to
which it gives existence let's take that
one more time
it is irrational to think we can't this
doesn't really make sense that something
would exist through that to which it
gives existence so if one thing makes
another thing exist we'll call this
thing a right thing a is the cause of
things B thing thing B's existence thing
B cannot be causing A's existence
because otherwise there wouldn't be
anything aid to cause thing B the the
cause effect relation is not a
reciprocal one at least in terms of this
issue as the Anselm is working it up so
he gives a little bit of further
discussion he talks about relational
terms
right he says they don't exist through
each other in this way what are
relational terms master and servant
father and son you know we can go on and
on and out as these sorts of things they
says when a master and servants stand in
relation to each other the men who stand
in relation do not in any way exist
through each other so you can't have a
master without having a servant and you
can't have a servant without having a
master but master and servant are not
existing things they are the relations
between existing things namely two human
beings so the two human beings don't
cause each other's existence he says
they don't state they don't exist
through each other and their relations
by which they're really they do not in
any way exist or each other they exist
through their subjects and in some takes
this as a good reason or good line of
reasoning to say that you can't have
this possibility that the things that
cause other things to exist sort of the
fundamental basis for metaphysics exist
through one another in a kind of
reciprocal causal relation so what we're
stuck with is this or this or this and
as we can see they all amount to the
same thing which is that there is one
supreme being why is it the supreme
being all the other existing things
exist through it since it is the cause
of their existence it is greater than
any of them and nothing causes it to
exist and we'll talk about that a little
bit more in videos yet to come